okay you're wasting your day I'm not
doing any interviews
my next comments will be on LBC on my
program with David Manor at 10 o'clock
tomorrow morning so don't waste all your
time column you don't spit on my dog are
you worried about the child labor party
are you Java she didn't just leave me
I'm not doing any interviews until my
obviously program at ten o'clock on
Saturday with David Miller I can people
in Sidon your opinion today if you
worried about them at the self in the
party yeah although I'm Fred Astaire
interest my team they got a tune into
LBC 97.3 tomorrow at ten o'clock
do you think that isn't a problem I know
you got to stop one of these gets read
on the dog god I know you don't care
about me but do please value the job
yeah
is there a problem of anti-semitism in
the party it's a serious question can
you can phone into the program like
members of the public do on Saturday if
you want what do you think of John man's
conduct yesterday a week away from a
loco I don't will you please not put yo
mind over Triskelion Schwab not cocaine
attack on my local imagine the mayoral
election next week but see leading
figures of the native party thousands in
front of the U K power I wasn't able to
this go back and check your TV show so
you had a like to sleep um it's you
regret come up with made yesterday
tune in on sadly I got a little saloon
onset Lee okay daddy
you